all right so tonight's first story RFK
has been slammed is anti-Semitic for a
claim he made that there's a
conversation that needs to be had
surrounding some allegations that covid
is more likely to in fact or is more
likely to result in mortality among
certain ethnic groups so we can watch
this video right now and then we'll talk
about what some of the people in The
Press are saying about him
oh actually do you think YouTube might
get mad at us if we play this whole
thing why
there's no I don't think so yeah all
right we'll play it
you hearing that no I'm not getting any
audio all right well it's not coming
through the audio well we get that
working
um we're just gonna we can talk about it
yeah we're just gonna explain this so
basically
RFK said as I mentioned and he wasn't
even saying that he necessarily believed
that this was the case but he's saying
that there needs to be a conversation
surrounding the fact that according to
him certain studies are showing that
covet does seem to disproportionately
affect certain people and he was
claiming that the effect that it's
having on people is based on genetic
factors that are linked to ethnic or
racial background now I find it very
interesting that the left is losing
their minds about this because they were
actually saying very similar things
about kova during the pandemic yes this
was early on the CDC was saying that
covet had a greater impact on black and
brown communities right they were saying
this specifically they were saying too
that if you were not taking covet
precautions you were not only killing
grandmas but you were racist yeah
because you weren't paying enough
attention and I think it's interesting
because they also made this a
justification for allowing people of
color to take the vaccine first so this
was a right there were a whole lot of
affirmative action style policies
surrounding coved the implementation of
treatment all of these things and now
you're not allowed to say that well
exactly I mean they were constantly
claiming that the African-American
community in particularly the black
community was being disproportionately
affected by coven because of this we
needed to be sure that they got the
vaccines first and so RFK he's saying
something a bit different because he is
outwardly making the claim that this is
based on genetic predisposition he's not
necessarily cultural factors but I don't
even know if he's making that claim no
he's just saying that is a claim we have
to investigate exactly but what happens
when we listen to this and if you listen
to him talking he starts it off as
saying there's an argument that and then
he starts talking that this does this
and this does this and if you take it
out of context it sounds like he's
saying this does this and this does this
but he preempts it with there's an
argument that there are like genetic bio
weapons basically right yeah and there's
even a news yes yeah in fact this
Newsweek so maybe we can pull up the
Pentagon making uh race specific bio
weapons to Target citizens China says
according to Newsweek China is making
the claim that the Pentagon is doing
race-specific bio weapons uh and this is
his this is as recent as May May 11th of
2023. yeah well and when I saw the so
our K put up this long thread on Twitter
saying the New York Post is taking me
out of context they are Mis
misrepresenting what I've said here is a
specific link to a study here's what I
meant by this and he ultimately demanded
that they issue an apology because he
feels like do you know if they did did
they the story is still up and I haven't
seen any apologies no correction at all
no correction as far as I could see uh
or at least acknowledge correction uh
and again some of this is maybe they are
making an editorial decision I'm sure
you can speak to this uh well our
reporter took this quote and
uh well what's interesting too is if you
look at the headline and you look at the
story they don't really match so it
seems like I know John Levine wrote the
story I wonder if John Levine wrote the
headline or if someone else wrote that
headline I know you guys are in a
newsroom right like we have people doing
Graphics we have people doing headlines
we have people writing stories and the
graphic the headline and the story could
all come from completely different
people on the you know the same team and
it's all sort of blurbs you're saying
like oh this is what it's about right I
think it's interesting uh to me my first
instinct when I see these kinds of
conflicts is to say like wow RFK really
has them on the ropes they they do not
like this yeah I mean I mean this is
them really starting to launch into the
Trump treatment of RFK so for a while
they were saying he's a quack he's
spreading misinformation he's a hawkster
he's trying to sell snake oil and fool
people about the Medical Science for his
own personal cane the typical kind of
stuff you hear about anyone who gets
labeled a conspiracy theorist by The
Establishment but now they're actually
moving into this guy's racist territory
right they're openly referring to him is
an anti-semite simply because he said he
wanted to have a discussion about the
degree to which covet seems to have
affected different populations now of
course the left was very comfortable
having the conversation about the
effects covet had on different
populations again in 2020 in 2021 when
they claimed it was disproportionately
affecting the African-American Community
there's anyone who can recognize
anti-Semitism it should be the people on
the Democrat side because they are
really anti-semitic in a lot of cases
pramila J Apollo came out the other day
and was saying that Israel is a racist
State you have ilhan Omar who is
decidedly anti-semitic
um you know it it seems to be in a lot
of cases what the Democrats accuse other
people of doing is the thing that they
are doing themselves all the time well
all the time and there's another element
to this which is really important that I
want to flag they're using this term
bioweapon right they're saying he's a
conspiracy theorist he's saying covid is
a bio weapon and this is a term that
people will generally associate with
conspiracy theory and because it's so
bombastic it sounds frightening but
according to Sir Francis Boyle the
American author of the American
implementing legislation of the
international bio weapons convention
anything created through gain of
function research is a bio weapon this
is the legal definition so if it's
created through gain of function
research which many of these
institutions are not acknowledging given
that they're saying lab leak hypothesis
is more than likely than it is a bio
weapon that's not a controversial claim
that's literally what the law says
that's literally what the man who wrote
the law has said about it and what the
left has done is guess what labeled him
a conspiracy theorist even though he's
literally the person who is responsible
for implementing that legislation in
writing around it and they're saying
he's a lawyer not an epidemiologist how
can he be saying it's a biological
weapon well because whether something's
a biological weapon is not a question of
epidemiology it's a question of Law and
he literally wrote the thing this is
something that's bothering me right now
so I'm looking at the New York Times
article titled Robert F Kennedy Jr airs
bigoted new covet conspiracy theory
about Jews and Chinese is that the
article in question I haven't read the
article yet no it's a New York Post
article New York Post okay all these it
looks like these other other outlets are
picking up the the claim it's like a
game of telephone and to be fair you
could see it all over Twitter too
everyone starts coming out saying that
RFK is racist and anti-semitic and
hateful and all of these kinds of things
it really it really was this classic
Snowball Effect where you have
um you know one headline
drove everything a lot of the people who
were talking about this story I wonder
if they even read the article or watched
the interview or just ran with the
headline I'm looking at the guardian now
white house condemned the White House is
now chiming in on it so it's not just
news organizations sister condemned this
statement but this is the thing that's
interesting about rfk's role in his own
family from the get-go he was the
media's favorite new conspiracy theorist
right the day that he announced that was
one of the first things that came out he
questions vaccines he's a conspiracy
theorist and you know regardless of the
fact that you don't necessarily have to
take medical advice from a politician I
understand that it is interesting that
this was the brand they were going to
use to uh to hurt his campaign from the
beginning and now they're just sort of
going back and trying to find more
evidence of this and that's why I think
it's an important conversation to have
was this quote accurately represented in
the article uh is he referring to a
study is he himself
promoting false information because if
you don't know that it's easy to then to
assume he is in fact practice deranged
person right yeah how quickly we forget
everything we forget the beginning of
covid we forget all of these um
conspiracy theories that as they were
called about the lab leak and everything
else that have proven out you know what
I mean there's that have proven to be
true yeah absolutely well there's
another element to this too there's a
couple things I want to mention here
firstly this strikes me
as RFK having his Jewish space lasers
moment so for those who don't know
Marjorie Taylor green is constantly
slandered as having said there are these
Jewish space lasers it's total nonsense
before she was ever elected to office
she made a very long Facebook post where
she was saying things which by the way
I'm not defending I don't agree with but
she was basically saying that she
thought that forest fires were started
by uh or potentially started she
basically floated the question they may
have been started by a satellite which
was funded by organizations that people
claim it is anti-Semitic to criticize
she never it's basically the equivalent
of saying oh if you say something
negative about George Soros you're an
anti-semitic conspiracy theorist
Marjorie Taylor green never ever ever
said the Jewish space lasers thing it's
complete nonsense even left-wing fact
Checkers have said that that's not
exactly true they've given it a mixed
factuality rating which is ridiculous
because it's it is totally false but
when you read their rationality say well
no she never said there were Jewish
space lasers she just said that this
space satellite uh that was funded by
groups that anti-semites don't like
might have started the fire so I guess
my point is this is another example of
the media and the left-wing
establishment seeing somebody is a
threat and wanting to take everything
they're saying totally out of context
and I gotta be honest I've mentioned
that I think RFK has problems there's a
lot I don't agree with him on obviously
I'm a conservative so I'm not going to
agree with him on quite a lot but I felt
similarly about Trump I'm not saying
I'll ever support RFK I could never
support a pro-choice candidate but I
remember when Trump first came out of
the scene I remember thinking I'm not a
huge fan of this guy and then I saw who
his enemies were and what they were
saying about him and how they were
smearing him and I began to warm up to
him so the media is playing a very
dangerous game if their goal is to get
people to hate RFK because the American
people know at this point that if you're
an enemy of a press the Press you're a
friend of the people yeah I think that's
so true well and if you're an enemy of
the Democrats you're probably a friend
of the people too I've got them
like these organizations somebody maybe
somewhere actually saw it out of context
and was like he said these things and
then they printed it and then whether
not they believed they were going to get
him out of context and make stuff maybe
they're making stuff up maliciously
maybe they actually thought it but I
think that then the White House and the
people in the obiden the obiden camp
Obama
let's just let's go with it we he's our
biggest threat he's obviously gonna win
the presidency if he's not slandered and
stopped and he's the biggest threat to
the medical pharmaceutical do you think
he has a chance of winning the
presidency well Michelle Obama
apparently is going to run so no what
about Gavin Newsom he seems to be he'll
probably be Michelle's VP probably I
think so I think if Michelle runs
Newsome won't stand a chance Michelle
Obama have any more qualifications than
Hillary Clinton did I think she has less
I think she actually has less Secretary
of State yeah yeah thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time